Okay, so in this section for nodal point,
we're going to talk about tracked object creation.
Now, we are going to do this in the engine,
so we're actually going to build our tracked object.
But before we do,
we want to see what it is that we
actually need for our tracked object creation.
Now, we have already provided you with
a OptiPuck track FBX which is going to
match any motive tracking puck
that you have if you're using the motive system.
If your system is different,
you will need to model
your FBX object that you're going to be used for tracking.
You're also going to need to make sure that
any tracking system that you
have has that model that's available.
These models don't exist in the engine,
but we are providing them for you as we have
modeled them to use in our own system here.
Now, let's go ahead and jump back into
the engine so that we can start importing our FBX.
Now, if you see here,
I am in my calibration folder and I need
another folder to make my objects
for nodal point having a place to live.
So let's go ahead and right-click and create
a new folder and we're going to call this one nodal point.
As I mentioned, this is where
my nodal point objects are going to live.
So once that's created, go ahead and double-click this open.
Now, let's right-click so we can import
to the engine our calibration object.
So once you hit the import object,
you are going to look for our OptiPuck track FBX,
and you're going to go ahead and hit open to import this.
This will bring up our FBX import options,
and there's not really much that you want to
make changes to in this list except if you
haven't already built it correctly in
centimeters and facing the front x-axis,
just check these on.
They won't really do anything if they're built correctly,
but you can check them on in order
to make sure that this is active.
Now, by default, your import texture should be checked on,
but if it's not, make sure that's
checked on so that the texture comes with it,
because we want to be able to modify
that texture in order to change the color
and make sure that this stands out
a little bit better in the world.
So let's go ahead and hit import all,
and you're going to get a little bit of
an error that comes up in here,
and we're going to go ahead and ignore that,
and then we're going to look for our OptiPuck track static mesh,
and we're going to open this up.
Now, we didn't get our material to come in here,
so I'm going to type in a Lambert
and see what we've got in here.
I've got my wall Lambert,
and I've got another one in here.
Right now, I've assigned it,
but I'm just going to locate this,
which is going to be located in our NDC,
under our NDC materials,
and I'm going to do this in order to
use an existing material that is already in here.
Now, this material,
I'm just going to change the name of this.
So we're going to call this OptiPuck track,
and we also want to move this
into our Nodal Point folder,
because we want to make sure that these are all kept together.
So, since we're adding these two pieces in here,
let's go ahead and make an alteration to my parameters.
I want to choose a nice default color value in here.
Let's go ahead and select the color value
inside the material for our OptiPuck track,
and I'm going to choose a really bright green here.
I'm going to really crank this up
so it's really easy to see.
So once that's done, I'm going to go ahead and hit OK,
and then I'm going to apply and save.
Now, if I come back over to my OptiPuck track mesh,
and you'll see that my puck itself
is actually going to be green as well,
once I change the Lambert to match.
And since we called this as M underscore Opti,
that's going to bring this up, and let's connect that.
Now, the reason that I wanted to make sure
that this is that color
is so that it stands a little bit easier.
And if I look at this mesh, again,
I want to point out that there is a bump on the front
and not on the back
so that you can see which direction is forward.
Otherwise, all four corners here have to match.
It's also going to allow you to see
where we're going to be putting our center control.
Now, once that's done, I'm going to go ahead and hit save,
and I can close this window
because I'm pretty much done in here.
Now, again, I want to make sure that these get added
because I'm using source control.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit source control,
mark for add.
I want to make sure that this gets changed to a plus.
Now, if it doesn't change to a plus
because I'm in an active session,
all I need to do to make sure that that happens
is go in here and persist my session changes.
Now, you can see all these changes that are in here.
I'm going to go ahead and hit persist,
and hopefully this goes through
and makes those changes happen.
Now, it did fail to persist with one error.
I'm not going to worry about that error just now
because I still got the add for the two components
that I wanted to work with.
Now, if I jump and take a look at my slides here,
there is a next step in our tracked object creation.
So as I mentioned,
we are using that bright green that's in here,
and I've got my tracked object.
I do want to make sure that we are working through here.
So things that we need to add to this
is we need to add a component controller
for the OptiPuck track
that is assigning this to our component.
And then I also need to add in
some static mesh components for some calibration points.
Now, let's go through and start by adding in
our calibration points rather than our track section.
So let's jump back to the engine.
Okay, looking at our object,
we need to make sure that this is already in the engine.
So I'm going to take my tracked object.
I'm going to make sure that I'm in the NDC level.
Right now I'm in my persistent level.
I need to make sure that I'm in my NDC level
because this is going to be part of my NDC.
So as I move in here,
let's go ahead and move this into place,
and then let's press F to focus in on it.
Now, as I move this in place,
I am going to want to be able to see what's happening
right in the middle of my screen.
I've got my front facing me,
so I am looking in the front here,
and this is exactly what I need.
Now let's start by adding in components.
I'm going to move over to my details panel
while my object is selected.
So I'm making sure that this is selected in my outliner.
I'm going to go ahead and move my OptiPuck track
to my offset actor.
And one thing I need to do before that
is I noticed that my mesh is set to static.
I need to adjust that to movable.
So I move over into my details panel,
change that from static to movable,
and now I can add this to my track offset actor.
Now I need to add components.
So as I mentioned here,
I've got my OptiPuck track selected.
I'm going to go ahead and hit add,
and that's going to add a calibration point.
So I've typed in calibration point,
and I'm going to rename this CP underscore,
BTM for bottom, and left.
So my first one here is the bottom left.
Now I'm going to need a couple more of these,
so let's go ahead and just duplicate that.
This one, I'm going to change the name to bottom right.
So instead of L for left, I'm going to use R for right.
I'm going to go ahead and duplicate that again.
And this one, I'm going to rename center,
and I'm going to just type out center.
Now I'm going to go ahead
and duplicate my bottom left again,
and I'm going to change this from L1 to top left,
and we're going to duplicate this just one more time.
I'm going to call this one top right.
So now I have each of these points here,
but they are all located in the same position.
Now they're going to need to be put
into a specific location,
and that offset position is going to need to align them
with my actual OptiTrack point.
So that alignment here is going to need to be adjusted
in centimeters to this position.
So let's start with all of them right now,
although we can deselect our center,
because our center is already in the center.
So let's go with our bottom left.
Now our location here,
if I just go ahead and go 4.5 centimeters,
and go this one 4.5 as well,
and now you'll see that my point is pretty much lined up
in that corner.
Now it's not quite where I want it,
so let's make another adjustment here
and change that from 4.5 to 4.75,
and do the same on this side here as well.
So now they're both in this location.
Now this is actually my top right,
so let's go ahead and move this over
by removing my top right and my bottom right from my set
and on my Y-axis make these negative 4.75.
So that's going to align these in the middle here
a little bit better.
Now your position may be a little bit different than mine
just because it's facing this
and I'm expecting a different change.
But now that I've got these set up,
I'm going to switch over to my bottom numbers
that are in here, I've got them selected.
They have multiple values in here,
but this one I'm just going to go ahead and hit a negative
and now they'll move to the bottom in here.
So now if I cycle through each one of these,
you can see them move in each of the corners
and into the middle so that they're aligned correctly.
And if I scroll around here and tumble around my model,
you can see each one is lined pretty close to the center
of each of these calibration points.
Now, once that's done, I do need this object
to actually be tracked to something.
So with this selected, I do need to add in a new component.
So that component is going to be my tracked object point.
So for that, if we jump back to our slides briefly,
right here is my tracked object creation
for my Live Lake tracking.
So for this, I go ahead and add in another component.
So let's jump back to the engine here
and I go in to make sure my OptiPuck track is selected
and I hit add and I go Live Link
and I'm going to go with another Live Link controller.
So this Live Link component controller
is going to be called Live Link LL underscore CC
for Live Link component controller,
OptiPuck and underscore TRK for track.
Not quite so many Rs, we're not a tiger or a pirate,
we're just going to keep that one track.
Now with that selected, I am going to make sure
that my subject representation gets changed here as well.
So I'm just going to move right down here
to my Live Link subject representation
and if I go in here,
you can already see that with my Live Link,
I have several active objects
because I've already created my Nodal Puck for tracking.
So again, back in my details panel,
right in the Live Link tab,
right down here for subject representation,
let's go ahead and select my Nodal Puck for tracking.
Now you'll see that that disappeared from the screen
and that's because right now,
it's actually tracked by the position
of the puck on the stage.
So if I switch to my stage view,
you can see that I've got my camera's puck.
The puck itself there has all four of those little options
and you can see the puck is kind of floating behind
where it's supposed to be, but it's not exactly aligned.
You can see that green kind of behind the puck itself.
Now you'll also note that I put a little sticker
in the middle, that's so that I know where to click
when I go ahead and do our Nodal Point calibration.